julianne hough takes a fun girls trip if  Julianne Huff's recent vacation pics are  any indication blonde definitely have  more fun on Monday the 27 year old  actress headed south of the border to  Cabo San Lucas Mexico joined by her mom  and three older sisters they sailed they  rode horses they did water yoga and  looked undeniably gorgeous in every  single shot so amazing the all girls  getaway comes just one month after it  was revealed the former Dancing with the  Stars Pro would not be returning to the  judge's table for Season 22 her brother  Derek told ET I think she did three sea  Krait seasons and it's time for her to  go the grease live star also is set to  Wed her fiance hockey star Brooks like  could this tropical vacate be her last  before becoming a married woman either  way Julianne said it best herself it's  done I'm living my dream too so I feel  very blessed